a bail bondsman former president a
psychologist a contemporary artist and a
porn producer sounds like the lineup for
politically incorrect in reality their
characters all brilliantly portrayed by
our five nominees for Best Actor in a
supporting role Robert Forester and
Jackie Brown
Anthony Hopkins in Amistad
greg kinnear in as good as it gets
[Music]
Burt Reynolds in Boogie Nights
[Music]
Robin Williams in Good Will Hunting
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Robin Williams
[Applause]
previously denominator
this is his first Academy Award
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
oh man this might be the one time I'm
speechless oh thank you so much for this
incredible honor thank you for putting
me in a category with these four
extraordinary men Thank You Ben and Matt
I still want to see some ID
thank you guys fans and for being so
subtle you're almost subliminal I want
to thank the cast and crew especially
the people of South Boston you're a can
of corn you're the best I uh I want to
thank the muskoka Weinstein Mazel Tov
and I want to thank Marcia for being the
woman who lights my soul on fire every
morning god bless you and most of all I
want to I want to thank my father up
there the man who when I said I wanted
to be an actor he said wonderful just
have a backup profession like welding
thank you god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]